what's up everyone we have the latest
Flagship from Google this is the Google
pixel 8 Pro the pixel 8 Pro is spotting
a nice little bit of change in terms of
the GPU it uses compared to other
Flagship phones out there and even
Android gaming phones that we've seen
this year which we will be going through
in a bit for now all you have to know is
that we will be putting it through our
gaming Gauntlet of hry stario kin impact
Call of Duty mobile which you'll be
playing with this spiffy backbone
controller and of course pubg mobile
performance- wise the pixel 8 Pro is
running the Google tensor G3 chip its
GPU which is a refreshing change is the
immortalis g15 mp10 we have 12 gigs of
RAM and we've got 128 gigs of storage
the display is a 6.7 in super actual ltp
OLED screen running at 120 HZ so before
we start the test let's do a baseline of
the temperatures with our trusty
temperature gun so something from the
front 27 all right of course nothing too
funky 29 we barely hitting 30 here okay
we just hit 30 over there at the bottom
let's check the
back okay something from here and over
the camber module still 28 is nothing
hting
30 and let's see all right look at that
the bottom on there okay just a little
bit but you know what it's nothing funky
so we've got that settled in out the way
let's just play our first game honkai
Star all right so we're in honai Star
right now and let's just check some
things real quick
you're Curr the highest for everything
we're at 60 FPS and everything's looking
pretty good and let's just check our
characters real quick ja part looks
pretty good and so far it doesn't look
like there'll be any huge FPS drops if
we just quick swap to any other
characters on here so I think we're
doing pretty
okay all right very nice A little bit of
her drop on there just a little bit but
uh let's bounce real
quick turn really
okay w keys if I'm not
wrong nice okay let's do an Alti real
quick just to test it out let's see how
the phone handles samples Al three and
also we are speeding things up toay myom
I
charge okay let's go
TR other thing is that the speakers are
located the side here so you know if you
I recommend using headphones or earbuds
for this
for like many others out there in the
market nice let's get
shields all right now
broken all right let's
welome all right wackies a little bit of
frame drops over here like look at that
it's it's kind of going out quite a bit
right now used to be at 60 but now it's
kind of barely keeping it at 50
the look at that it's going down quite a
bit go all
right oh nice okay oh okay I I didn't
realize we beat both of them at the same
time okay sick and with that let's check
temperatures real
quick all right 35.9 35.6 honestly it's
not that warm on the front or at least I
didn't notice it that much 38.3
39 hit the 40 regions I
believe oh it barely hits 40 okay 38.6
37.2 40ish around here remember there's
no cover here so it's just the phone on
its on 41.3 on the camera
modules camera modu about
37 and the top here looking at about
35.4 so honestly not too bad we are also
currently at 8 88% we down we started up
at 93% so we're down 88 that's 93 92 91
20 28 93 92 91 90 89 88 that's 6% 6% in
about I don't 6% in about 15 minutes so
it's doing pretty well so far so with
that let's move on to our next game gang
chin impact okay so currently we are at
85% battery let's check temperatures
before we hop into get impact and let's
see
34 35 yeah it's cool down a little bit I
had to stop for a bit to let our camera
cool down so that's why the battery is
different but other than
that we've given the the phone a little
chance to breathe which we don't usually
do
though uh here 36 37 36 all right here's
here's pretty all right all right now
we're in eng imp pack let's just check
settings real quick but oh okay so
currently we set everything to the
highest over here 60 FPS and yeah things
are looking pretty good as I'm just
Turing the camera
around there is it doesn't hold up 60
FPS no it does not that look looks great
let's go to a all right a little bit of
a fre drop there oh okay that's quite
that's quite a bit freeing drop all
right
that let's get back to
K so as you can see there is a little
bit of a FY
drop when changing characters but other
than that I think we're fine let's just
run through in a Zuma and see how this
form
performs okay yeah we're running at 20
FPS right now it's not holding up pretty
well it's not oh oh my Lord okay but
again again genchi and honkai are pretty
damn demanding of these phones so yeah
as you can see we're not doing we're not
doing so hard right now all
right but maybe after an update or two I
oh my Lord
okay oh
boy all right Alti oh boy o okay not so
cash
money not very cash money no wor and
let's just get another Al
going okay so when we stack
alties it doesn't look too
good o okay
tode beautiful stuff again the phone
can't really handle everything at 60 FPS
so just keep that in mind let's get this
on wrong direction but it's okay we're
taking them all down come on let's
[Music]
go bit
more all right that's it okay so with
that let's just check temperes right now
we are at
79% and temperature looking pretty good
I honestly besides the performance that
we've been seeing I would expect a bit
more but other than that we're doing
pretty all right with temperatures all
right let's check the back real quick
and currently we at 34% 33 it's actually
doing not too bad I I'd say it is a
pretty all right tradeoff that you're
not burning your fingers off with this
thing but still the performance does
need a little bit of a check so just
keep that in mind it may be that the
phone isn't out yet that's why the
optimization isn't that great but also
it could be the
hardware but you know let me know what
you think leave that in the comment
section below below all right and with
that let's get to our next game Call of
Duty mobile which will be playing with
the backbone this channel is supported
by Brands who help us improve our
content and keep us going so stay around
for this sponsored message here at geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this mix of
Forman function helps the Titan Evo 2022
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co all right so we are hot off
genin impact we're currently at 78% and
let's just check temperatures real
quick all right so far at
32 here wow it has cooled down quite a
bit all right 34
33 34
again and yeah it's it's doing all right
let's check the back it does dissipate
heat pretty efficiently if I'd say so
and let's check the camera modules not
too bad 33.5 34 35 34 yeah nothing wrong
okay it has gone down quite a bit from
what we last saw with genin impact so
with that let's just hook up the
backbone we're also currently at 77%
right now we have this all locked and
loaded put to Graphics real quick and
set everything to Max I can only go
higher Max so that thing does not agree
with each other so keep that in mind uh
BR that's fine all right everything is
turned on for br and I think we should
be good to go can we Sprint oh okay
everything is
set cool cool cool cool all I have to
say is that I'm going to have a good
time with this thing because it really
brings me the proper Call of Duty
experience with the controller all right
let's get into
it frame drops in there
again next Graphics nextx
FPS and I'm
alone oh let's not go dark let's go farm
yeah you know what let's go to
farm doing pretty good so far little a
little bit of three drops here there but
okay we we're doing okay so far let just
go first person just so we can get the
proper experience so the thing about the
backbone is that once you put your phone
in it it kind of automatically I mean
with with some adjustments here and
there you will automatically assign all
of these functions to the buttons here
so currently the volume's at the highest
I believe oh okay getting shot at where
at oh I see
you come
on there you
go I'm compensating a bit too much right
now but yes finally some
combat okay we're both equally
terrible okay that's one down finally
but uh okay run at a nice
60 so
oh in there someone on me what the
hell oh there you are
he's probably inside
here oh there you
go okay it's one
down
oh okay Qui scoping down
oh come
on it's not really a quick scope but you
know what that works out Al so one thing
I noticed at the bottom of the
controller you can actually attach a 3.5
mm Jack here any USBC y here for
charging your phone while you game so
that's pretty neat and so far nothing
much has been going on I've been pretty
much on my own I still have like 26 guys
to have to kill if I can find anyone
else to kill but performance has been
doing pretty great so far
oh someone's on
here there we go
all right incom oh what the
okay yeah I kind of wasted a l time
right there but you know what never
mind where's this guy
ni team close toct oh one more guy there
you
are okay so that's
it all right so that's all let move this
one the controller real quick the
backb all right
and here we go 33% oh 33° c
sorry the game Holly be at end in the
four so performance again is
concerning as much as I'll
see the back 35
34 is doing all right on the Tho front
but again performance isn't looking that
amazing on this thing and we're at 70%
right now so hm with that let's get to
our final game pubg mobile so before we
get into pubg mobile let's check
temperatures real quick we're currently
at 69% nice and let's check
temperatures all right
28.6 all right things has cooled down
quite a bit I mean given or so we are in
a room temperat slightly below room
temperature environment cuz you know
there's an acon here and let's check
this out 29
29.3 all right very cool very cool
indeed okay so with that pubg mobile
let's check our
settings settings wir is because you
guys asked for it I will deliver we
smooth for graphics and extreme for
frame rate everything else four times
anti-aliasing and we going to press okay
for that and you know with that we're
going to restart the game and then play
a match and are we going to jump off
okay we're jumping off right now so as
you can see I'm not going to be control
anything obviously cuz I'm following the
J Master but it's running pretty smooth
so far pretty steady 60 FPS so
interesting to see that let me just
check the graphics real quick I don't
think there's a 90 on this yeah there
isn't it's just extreme
so let's just get into it and hopefully
touch down soon enough hopefully I'm
going to be unfollowing this guy he
going to go hit straight down all the
way down and then get weapons and then
we'll start
hopefully the
gunfights okay we're almost there I'm
going to be up the I'm not even
going to try guessing whether that's
East or West so KY
doys very nice uh drops in there but
we're doing a
okay I think nothing too concerning just
yet and it's dark again for some reason
why does it keep doing
that oh boy oh boy I'm getting shot at
there we go oh okay not using
controls yet but um at least he's
down K this one guy down
location
there's another guy
here very nice this one's caught down I
mean honestly we're not playing pubg on
like very demanding graphics and
honestly it's just playing at 60 FPS so
all in all it's doing pretty All For
What It's
with okay let's just heal oh okay I see
him it's behind the r over
there
we go one guy over
there okay that's two guys
down very
nice okay nice there another Squad
down all right one guy
down
[Music]
oh damn okay well okay that that kind of
ends thing for
me all right never mind it's all good
cuz I think we got what we needed and we
are currently at 62% so with that let's
check the temperates real
quick 33 I mean it was a bad play but
you know 34.9
35 34.8 all right let's check the back
you know it's it's pubg it's doing
pretty all right honestly the main
concern is mostly with genin and honkai
but other than that I think we're doing
pretty good for this one so with this
let's just get
into our final thoughts the Google pixel
8 Pro as you've seen from the footage is
going to give Google quite a bit to
reflect on post launch whether I can
chalk it up to the games optimization
for genin and honka is one thing but at
least performance isn't super bis just
very L luster I will give it credit for
its thermal performance and for how
efficiently heat is reduced throughout
both games though for Call of Duty
mobile and pubg mobile it ran both games
without a hitch battery performance
after playing four games for about 2
hours going from 95% to well 59% is
pretty all right not super amazing but
impressive nonetheless Google still has
a way to go when it comes to perfecting
their pixel phones but they're on the
right track so far and I hope they stay
steady on that path and and also I must
say the backbone has been quite the
addition to the gaming videos expect to
see more of this for future videos so
would you be getting the pixel 8 Pro let
me know in the comment section below
leave your questions there too if you
have any and we'll do our best to get to
them if you like what we do make sure to
follow us on all our socials right here
and maybe leave a like And subscribe to
us it goes a long way if you want to see
more stuff check this
out